hello my name is Aaron Hall I'm 27 years
old I am from Ohio but I live in Los
Angeles actually
I am in Ohio right now and this is the
first time I've been to Ohio many years
I was seeking therapy because of Ohio
the state of Ohio was contaminated
um so I wore extra clothes that I could
throw away before I go back to LA so I
don't contaminate my apartment
um I threw away
um shoes and stuff in Los Angeles
because my brother went to my mom's
house that is contaminated in Ohio that
I won't go to
um and walked around La so certain
places in LA are were contaminated in me
and I accidentally wear my shoes because
I stepped where he stepped because he
went to my mom's house he went to my
mom's house and brought the
contamination to Los Angeles and I
stepped where he stepped so I had to
throw my shoes away and close away and
my girlfriend my actually my brother
um I don't fly I don't like to fly so my
brother actually came flew from my other
brother I have two other brothers
multiple Brothers I flew from Ohio to
Los Angeles to pick me up he picked me
up and flew back to Ohio because I have
really bad anxiety and
he he he uh once he got to Ohio you know
all right Aaron
Aaron where you from uh I'm from Elyria
Ohio well outside Cleveland pretty much
well it's like a small suburb outside of
Cleveland okay
tell me about your family growing up
um Family growing up I was adopted
um I was adopted at the age of
well I was in and out of foster care and
then I was officially adopted at the age
of five
and um and I was uh homeschooled
and um
and kind mom took her to public school
at an early age because I had a lot of
there was a lot of problems she saw me
and she knew that I wouldn't be able to
function in school correctly
and then who homeschooled us well
um while doing nursing hmm
how would you describe your childhood
um
difficult you lost your biological
parents or they lost you yes uh she they
they lost well we got taken away from
them because of a lot of violent stuff
um
uh and uh because a lot of like police
police will call it and
um
a lot of stuff was happening
um in that household
um that um that's why we were taken out
violence towards you or towards oh
towards me towards me and
my
uh
my blood biological mom
um and we were kept in our
well I don't want to say anything's
incorrect we'll kept in things were kept
inside the room locked usually well my
brothers were and then sometimes I'll
kind of go off and on it's the hardest
it's hard kind of hard I guess I'm gonna
explain it correctly but yeah we're like
locked in there pretty much
um and we were uh so a lot of stuff were
going on
in and out um in the household so that's
where and then more please we could be
would be called
um and then we'd be going to church
um so then they would see like they
would uh they would they would kind of
figure out eventually those stuff going
on in the house so then they uh
um so yeah then you know
um
you know more you know kind of in our
foster care is to the point where we got
adopted and the family that adopted you
was was a better family uh no this the
family I have now yeah yep that's great
yeah how old are you now I'm 27 27. yeah
you went through High School uh yes
homeschooled I went to school you got
home schooled
um and then I yeah
homeschool it and then
uh
yeah homeschooling so so you are OCD
I've diagnosed with a bunch of stuff
what kind of stuff were you diagnosed
with I was diagnosed with
um OCD
f-a-s-f-a-s-d which is fetal alcohol
fetal alcohol spectrum disorder and then
autism
hmm
there's a third and anxiety disorder
yeah
and I'm sure that
collection of
the well the collection of things that
don't make sense it's a collection of it
all
it all um it doesn't it's hard because
you have the OCD stuff that it's like a
whole different
brains part of your brain where where
you can't touch certain things or this
is contaminated or you know uh or you
can't be around you know you can't uh
you know you you know you haven't choose
a thought so you have so much going on
with that side then you have the autism
part where you gotta you know where you
are not good at communication that's
what I have not I'm not that's why I
beat I'm told a lot of my communication
skills isn't great
um social interaction isn't great and uh
stuff like that so you have that side
where you know I have a trouble
understanding social cues and reading a
situation correctly so they have all
this stuff that so there's like two and
then when you have those two
things happening
um it's like it's it's almost like you
know they're not they're not good
together at all yeah and it makes your
your life difficult I'm sure I'm sure oh
very difficult I can yeah very very very
difficult because
there's a lot of I mean there's a lot of
things that makes it difficult it's
harder for me to hold a job it's hard
for me to keep friends I can you know I
can I'll make a friend then I'll say
something offensive and then I'll
realize later on that well you're just
being mean you know but it's hard to
realize when I'm being mean when I don't
really recognize it hmm
and there's not really any medications
or treatments no I was so well I was on
Zoloft for my OCD
um at an early age did that help
I helped it helped it helped me like it
made me not think pretty much it helped
me not think I hope you mean like and
that was dedicated it does more towards
OCD and that helped me like function in
a way that I could touch things I can do
this I can do this I can do this
um and not have the intrusive thoughts
that I would have like oh this it would
just fix things but it also kind of like
made things bad because it would kind of
wipe up my memory in a way
um and then I
um because as I got older like you know
like I think I started I got back in
Zoloft when I was
um about two and a half years about two
years ago two and a half years ago is
and I got sick from it I got I got sick
and I was hallucinating so I was just
like um yeah I'm not gonna I can't do
medication anymore so I stopped
completing the medication and I've been
just doing um I've been seeing a
psychologist I've been seeing like I've
been going I went to a therapist you
know I've been just working on just
talking instead of uh
instead of medication is there anything
that that helps you
um yeah there's a lot of things that
help me like that I mean those things I
do like
um educational not educational
um like skateboarding helps me
um writing helps me and stuff like that
hmm
and emotionally what is it what does it
do to you do you get depressed or you
already have anxiety from oh I have
really bad anxiety I was told to have I
guess pretty much severe anxiety which
is like you know I I it's just like
every
it's like I don't know how I explain it
it says I get panic attacks a lot what
kind of things trigger it
I don't know no I don't know actually
because I actually before I came here
because I'm from Ohio but I've been
living I've been staying Ohio for the
last like six months because a lot of
stuff was happening my mental health was
very very bad very very bad
um so I needed to get help I was staying
I was living out here in La got evicted
from my apartment and then
um and I just trying to get help in Ohio
with my family and stuff
um
so now it's kind of like
wait I forgot what you said actually I
completely forgot what you just asked me
it's okay so I mean which of these
disorders is the most troubling for you
autism autism yeah definitely
um because it it holds me back from
um
it makes my it makes me not able to
figure out situation correctly and
holding a job correctly getting everyone
getting mad at me
um
and that's what makes things very
difficult how would you define autism
um Define it I I think for me it's like
one of those things that it's like um
I don't know actually it it seems to
affect different people differently well
for me it affects me um if communication
wise if that affects me in communication
wise and it makes and for my family of
my friends I am always told that I'm
rude
most of them are rude and my girlfriend
actually had to stop taking on her
friends because she was like and you say
whatever is on your mind you just say
things you know say things you know
stuff like that and it's true I will
just say things you know you won't
police yourself no I I just yeah I kind
of like if I have a question if it pops
my head and I and I want another
question I will ask the question you
know and I and that's the thing and it's
hard to hold back from it because it's
like then I will think and think about
that question until until I figure out
the question do they answer like I don't
even the answer to the question like I
need to know the answer
so you end up alienating people that you
don't want to alienate
um well it's like hey well what I maybe
I'm wording it right I'm not sure but
it's like it's like you know if you want
to know if like
give you an example it's like if
someone's like oh and I work it's
probably it's a good example those are
those are a girl in my work and I
thought C was uh
I couldn't tell she was a trans or not
and I was like now now I'm thinking like
well what if I thought she was
attractive does that make me gay now
this is the OCD stuff now it's OCD stuff
now I'm overthinking I'm thinking
thinking I think and thinking like oh is
that is that making gay then have I have
I thought she's attractive like but I
have a girlfriend so that means I'm
cheating wait a second wait a second my
mind is going crazy crazy and then I and
then I have to know the answer so then
I'm like and then and then then I'm
thinking like well crap
I know I I know a student asked a
question I shouldn't walk up and I asked
I shouldn't walk up and ask her I know
it's inappropriate so instead I want to
ask the manager instead
and I you know then then she told me no
and I was like okay now I'm like okay so
if I did think she's attractive if I did
doesn't mean I'm gay
so it's like it's like stuff like that
that makes if that makes sense and yeah
does this does this ruin your life oh
yes it does oh yeah I I think it does I
mean
well it's it's hard to it's yes it does
it it does in a lot of different ways
because
it um
it controls my life in just you know
friendships wise you know and you know
just just you know just like
um in the world like you know like my
like like it's almost like because when
I see my psychologist my you know and
we're in a room together it's almost
like it's like I have
it's like I'm I have there's no way I
can function this world without help
pretty much it's like that's how things
are once I'm by myself and I'm trying to
figure things out if everything falls
apart because I can't keep I can't keep
track of things I can't I can't uh
how do I word it I can't
um
I can't figure his situations out pretty
much that's that's pretty much it I
can't figure things out unless someone's
telling me what to do or if I have a
certain goal I can do it like like right
now I'm writing a book
um like so like right now I'm writing a
book and I can get that goal done and
but everything else
oh a music a good example I can play a
piano I can if I if I want to learn song
I will learn that song Or if I you know
if I want to learn an instrument I will
learn the instrument and I can do that
very very uh correctly I feel like but
when it comes to like you know you walk
in the room stuff like behind you
I will have trouble doing that because
I'll completely just forget
it's stuff like that it's little things
like that like you know don't worry
Susan the house and I wear my shoes in
the house because I completely forget I
have a very bad memory like poor I have
a I have a very good long-term memory
very bad short-term memory
very often people who have a disability
let's call it um like these that you've
described they have something else in
there
personality or in their their wheelhouse
that is you know a strength something
that they're very good at are there
things that you're very good at
skateboarding writing and music music
yeah those are those are those three
things and I those are three things I
know that I
I can um that I feel like I'm I'm I
don't like to say good because I feel
like it's bragging but I'm decent at I
can do it I can do and those things I
know that I bring me joy and I know that
I can I can execute it correctly I'll
bet you there are a lot of very
accomplished
artists musicians whatever that um
that might be
autistic but they uh they excel at
something and they just apply themselves
towards that yeah that's what makes
things actually difficult for me because
it's like
I need to be able to excel in regular
life stuff but I can't that's a problem
like right now we're like I can't I have
really bad holding a job so right now
I'm trying to we're waiting on my SSI
we're trying to get SSI in order because
we know that I I can't I can't work in a
job for me is very difficult because and
you know and it is in the thing that's
what makes it harder because
and I told my mom were talking about
this and I was just like I you know I
was like hold on I wish I was completely
like
completely like disabled completely
pretty much because it makes it harder
when I look I look normal and I'm I'm
putting that I'm I'm put there and I
can't figure it out
and everyone's like well why can't you
figure it out you look like you're
you're normal you know like why you look
normal like he figured out and I can't
you know that's that that's what makes
the things very very difficult and you
put in that category of like well do it
you know when you can't do it
what do you think people don't
understand about
autism OCD well I think people don't
understand with OCD is that it's it's
very a lot of people I've hear will say
oh I'm a little ocd-s I don't think OCD
is very very life controlling and I know
everyone has their own different
some are not severe
um in my case they're severe but I feel
like with people who have OCD they
um
um I was gonna say
it uh makes things more uh
makes things difficult definitely what
kind of every every OCD story I hear is
there's always some peculiar thing that
they
obsess over what kind of things do you
focus on
well contamination
contamination
um worrying about getting C while and
I'm glad I'm open about that now like
you know I I will say it I will say I'm
worried about getting gosh man C getting
what C
cancer c-a-n-c-e-r oh you're afraid to
say oh my gosh yeah I I try to keep that
out of my mind trying to keep that on my
brain actually on the way here I saw
somebody who just died from that and I
made me weak and I was just like oh man
I'm getting like that you know that weak
feeling you know like when you like hit
like a like an artery in your like and
you hit like you had like a like a
certain nerve in your body you feel like
a week you know I don't even felt like
that but that's how I felt just hearing
about that it freaks me out
so you're afraid of cancer yeah
definitely and and
um and growing up I was afraid of I
thought I had AIDS I thought I I thought
there's a lot of weird things I I was
scared bringing AIDS you know or I
scared about getting C or getting a
brain tumor I got to go to the doctor
every time I'm taking the doctors I
would like to check you like okay which
Aaron what's wrong with there now like
you know like well Harry thinks he has a
brain tumor now you know it's always a
pig addict see you know there's always
something you know but that's just my
yeah that's just me overthinking a lot
of situations
does your family kind of understand it
and uh work with it yes and frustrating
very frustrating it's frustrating for my
my brothers my brother is frustrating
for my mom because it makes things very
um difficult for her because
I'm constantly I'm not constant you know
like see College from the drama queen
pretty much like you worry about you
freak out over everything pretty much
which is true for Gora everything pretty
much I will I you know if I saw you know
so if I it's like someone sneezed in the
heads and they had C's they had the you
know the c word I would
be like I would all I would be thinking
like well crap that's that hurt that
stuff in her system has gotten inside of
me meaning that possibly there's a
chance that this stuff could grow inside
me now you know that's how that's what
my that's what my brain thinks like it
goes into
it goes you know are there things that
make it better or worse
um
opening of the body makes it better as
I've been recently doing been opening up
about about everything to be honest to
my mom well I a lot of things like I I
has a problem growing up I hate a lot of
stuff for my doctors my mom I was scared
to think what they were gonna say
growing up I had more there's a lot of
compulsives I have like I wouldn't you
know there's more of like um germulated
stuff I go like I'm always trying to
give me like I want to eat my mom's food
I want to eat food if you had gray hair
I wouldn't you know there's things like
that I would not um I would keep myself
you know from I would keep myself
separated from my family there would be
in the living room watching TV and I'll
be in the dining room because I wouldn't
want to be by them I don't want to redo
my own thing you know and they were like
well come in and join us like I don't
want to join you guys the how the couch
is disgusting this dog there's there's
been dogs on that couch and it's gross
and I don't want to be around you guys
because I don't want to touch anyone and
I'd rather sit here and watch TV from
the dining room while I was in the
living room
yeah hmm
do you have any friends I have a few
friends I have a few friends I they
understand what you're going through yes
they have a few friends they are with me
and they try to they talk to me and they
understand me and then you know one of
my friends said it takes a special
person you're on Aaron does I know a
good and I like that it's not it's
embarrassing in a way but at the same
time I'm realizing there's no you know
as I get older I realize there's no
there's no change you can't do anything
about it really besides try to do your
best do you feel like what you went
through with your biological family may
have
caused any of this
um well my my psychologist thinks that
my psychologist thinks that it's a lot
it's a lot for a young person yeah a lot
my psychology thinks that the stuff from
the past
stuff that or my my social worker
actually actually brought this up she
said the stuff for me from your past
even the smell of the weather will
trigger the stuff that you don't even
remember
from that past you know he does so much
trauma there just watching you know just
watching it but also having it to you
and you're so there's a little all that
stuff won't even like it won't you won't
you won't remember it but it'll be there
which is like I think which I think is
very you know it it happens to you know
when you go through that iPods I mean I
don't know directly correctly but of
everything
what is your general like perception of
the world are you are you just scared
all the time or do you see the world as
a beautiful place I see I
definitely paranoid a lot
definitely paranoidalized very I'm very
hard to trust people I have a very very
very I don't trust a lot of people
um and I try to trust people and then I
the thing is about and I think of that
and that's most I think it's mostly
because of my problem because the
problem is I
huh it's like when someone okay so it's
like when someone's laughing
I don't it's hard for me to tell if
they're laughing at me or with me so
it's like it's and then if you find out
later laughing at you you feel like you
feel like crap like dang yeah I mean so
it's like you it's like that that makes
things that causes him a problem that's
what builds up in you kind of that's
another part about you know that's
another part of you know it makes things
I guess you know what yeah I don't know
yeah hopefully it makes sense does it
yeah it does okay
um
do you have any regrets in your life any
things you wish you would handle
differently or huh yes a lot of got yeah
I I was a hand I handle I wish I would
handle a lot of things differently
the thing is is that it's
I don't know because I feel like
everything happens or reasons in a way
like I think it's supposed to happen if
you like you know
by the same time because if you don't if
certain things don't happen you won't
ever learn and that's what that's so any
mistakes I made in the past is because I
it's me learning are there are there
things that you said or did that that
you were you know maybe you heard
someone's feelings or you
you you pushed away a friend without it
without intending to do that is that the
kind of stuff that sometimes you'll
regret
um
yes and no I push a lot of people away a
lot of people away are you able to
control that behavior in the future and
not do it again or is it just something
that is going to happen anyway
I think for me is something that I
it's hard because it sticks in my brain
it's like the OCD almost exactly I don't
know I don't know what it to be honest
so it's like if something happens to me
or something happens a movie plays my
head over and over and over again with
the OCD exacerbates your autism yeah
well it's like a movie plays my head
over and over until I can get until I
get the information out and then once I
get to me and once I tell the
information out it usually doesn't it
usually is not always you know it's like
Iman would say Aaron you need to just
keep things to yourself but I see
anything directly actually say that but
it's like she kind of like says like you
know like you don't need to the whole
world doesn't need to know about your
issues right the problem is it's like
they don't she's right but at the same
time it's like
if something's on my mind I I need to
say it it will bother me until I say it
that's the problem with me it's like
eight well I will think keep thinking
and thinking and thinking thinking think
until I eventually get it out and then
once I get out I feel that relief and
then you know so like that's that's the
problem you know it's like I need to get
it out I need to get things out if I
feel that things need to be said I say
it I can't keep it inside me definitely
something that happened if it happened
to me I can't keep it inside me I have
to get it out because
it well it just damages me inside until
I get it out that's the OCD I don't know
what it is I mean it seems like those
two
kind of work hand in hand to take your
life down yes a lot of things have been
a lot down but I think that's what
that's unless I'm learning I'm learning
as I go out as I'm going as as things go
on I'm learning and learning and
learning and learning are you are you
improving your behavior or not improving
but are you changing your behavior
uh my changing my behavior are you able
to control it I don't know
I don't know if I can or not to be
honest where are you living now me yeah
I am huh I am
I kind of go back and forth so I was
staying in Ohio
so I was living out here in Los Angeles
I got it I um I couldn't pay I am I
mental health my mental health got very
very bad
and I wasn't you know I was just I
couldn't I couldn't function anymore I
feel like and I had to get help I
couldn't I got mad I think LA Care out
here and but they couldn't get the help
I needed
and my mom wanted me to come down but
like I was afraid to come to down to
Ohio because Ohio well first of all we
gotta worry about a plane I don't like
to fly
[Applause]
um
I learned to fly alone definitely so
um once I got to you know I was seeing a
therapist
out here in La who talked about my my
stuff in Ohio why why Ohio was
contaminated
well it's you know it in Ohio it's
contaminated to many reasons
um so it got I needed Ohio is
contaminated always
it was contaminated was contaminated yes
I because now I'm back I went there and
I'm back now like I I you know I mean
I'm saying I was I I got I'll explain it
so I
I was I wouldn't I wouldn't I haven't
been to Ohio since 2019
um because it was contaminated
um with what
well let me I would get to that point
um
I was seeing a therapist out here that
was I was talking about my issues
and and so you kind of got to the to the
to the point where it's like okay you
know you and I told her why what was
going on and then she was like okay you
know
you know we you know we did breathing
techniques and stuff like that and then
just me opening up to her helped me
and then eventually as you know time
went on my mom was like well one you
need to go to Ohio I'm like I can't
because you know if your house is
contaminated Ohio is I mean just just
being in Ohio is going to be hard for me
um but as my mental health got really
really bad I had pretty much no choice
right we're stacking up everyone was
stacking up I wasn't getting worse and
worse and worse and then
um I was like okay I have no choice but
to go to Ohio So eventually my brother
Anthony from lives in Ohio came
picked me up I'm the Arab like he came
on the airplane came to from Cleveland
to LAX
and
picked me up and then went back to Ohio
with me
and and then I got my mom's car which
was difficult for me of course and then
I've been staying at my brother's house
for brother's house for a while until
they got pretty much okay Aaron we
didn't think Aaron be here this long
he's very hard to live with he leaves
messes everywhere he puts clothes in the
cabinet and
um
he always has to have a seat on the
couch before he sits on it so you know
that got irritating and then after that
so I started so my mom's friend who
stayed with her was also homeless and
then she lived in a governor housing
place
so I end up staying with her sometimes
so I'll go back to my you know this is
actually this this is how things are now
still actually so I I go my brother's
house and the the governor housing back
and forth until my brother I just feel
like okay we need a break from you
not just a break from you just a break
because we have you know from the
situation you know we need time to have
a family so
then I go to the I go to the governor
housing place and then
I go back and forth you know and when I
was you know I was so that's what I've
been doing for the last six months
pretty much
um and then trying to get the
encouragement to go to my mom's house
was my mom's house was contaminated and
took a lot of it took a lot of you know
you know eventually then that six months
more actually to the end of the six
months since I came back to LA here I'm
as I'm sitting here right now
they
um
I eventually uh went to my mom's house
and I that's and that's and I won't sit
in my mom's house so I won't sit on any
furniture I will just I won't touch the
door knobs I will use my my feet to
touch the door and I'll open my shoes
whatever I won't touch it inside the
house but me as being being me being
outside the house has has almost thick
no I can't say it fixed my OCD but it
made things a lot more relaxed to me
because that was like the that was like
you know me going to my childhood house
things that
any mistakes I've made in there or
anything that made me feel gross or
anything it was all there and I realized
like if I can go to my mom's house you
know because you know I mean it all took
steps like you know Ohio first you know
going to my brother my brother Anthony's
house to my mom's house with all the
steps you know and because it was
happening was like even my my brother
Sean went to my mom's house and went to
LA you know I walked from my wore the
same suits from my mom's house to LA
I would know that oh yeah those are the
same shoes I went to Mom's house and you
touched this ground here so now this
ground is contaminated you know or you
know I can't walk around the ground
until it rains you know or now that I
touched where you walked I had to throw
my shoes away so it was actually time I
threw my shoes away because I watched
where he walked you know so that that
OCD side of me would would um would uh
would make things very very difficult
very it was like a long I had a lot of
lists you know and that's and that's
another thing too because like
my girlfriend who lives out here well
okay my I I don't know if he's my
girlfriend or not it's very complicated
situation right now but
she's like you can stay you can stay
with you can you can come stay with me
you know you have to pay but he's gonna
stay with me okay but I'm like okay but
you can't do your rituals you can't put
clothes in the cabinet you can't do this
you can't do that that's the problem you
know you know me leaving me staying when
we're living at the the 1453 Tamron
Avenue address on
um in East Hollywood I would
have a lot of rituals I'd put everything
in certain spots you know I'd put my you
know clothes up here put my towel up
here I'd put my clothes in the cabin up
here where the dishes go you know I
would I would have all these rules and
rituals you know and I you know so you
know so that's the that would make
things very very difficult for anyone
probably you know but that was very
annoying so it's kind of hard to live
with me in that in that aspect what's
your biggest fear now
like long term I don't know I I think I
don't I think you're afraid of things
like cancer and well yes but I think
that now it's kind of like I'm scared
that I'm not gonna be able to be able to
get into a better position I'm it's just
like I I feel like every time I try it
doesn't work
it doesn't work every time I try it's
like everything like I I think I go and
then bam I just fall down like it's like
it's a Constance what's your what's your
greatest strength what's your favorite
quality about yourself
um
I think I am creative
that makes sense yeah creative I'm sure
I'm sure there's something that excels
yeah because of almost because of all
the limitations you have yes well I am
very creative I know that I think so
Elise I think that I
can get things done when I need to get
things done when it involves like
material stuff like you know like
learning a skateboard trick I can get it
done I will go all out until I land that
trick same thing with writing if I if
I'm writing a book I have to get it done
so it's like stuff like that oh if I'm
you know if I'm you know if I'm working
on a project I have to get it done I
will get it done but if I'm but that
that that's the things I can excel in
but when it comes down to just life
stuff that's the problem that's that's
where I or interacting put me in a room
with a bunch of people it's not gonna
always be you know people aren't are not
gonna want to be around me they're like
this kid's weird or this kid's why did
she say that why you see it seems like
you know he says whatever he wants but
it's not really like that it's like I
just say what's on my mind
which makes things very difficult
because I kind of just speak
you know I'm very blunt I guess you
could call it I'm very I just go
straight to the point with me it's like
I will just tell you so it's like you
know it's in that that's the problem you
know that's the problem that I have too
that I need to work on is it comes off
as impolite
yes but people it's like
yes but it's like
I need to
learn how to not be straight forward at
people you know like not be so
yeah I don't know it's like it's it's
hard you learn to be two-faced like the
rest of us no
I can't do that very hard to me do that
actually hmm
um yeah
Aaron what would you say is the most
important lesson you've learned in your
27 years
I gotta be careful who I shot myself
with that's one thing I think after I'm
learning I gotta be very very careful
who I
um who I'm around that's that's that
that's why you know that's why one of my
biggest things I got to be very like
that's why I try to keep my well I'm
learning to keep my you know not just do
anything I got a very big that's that's
hard though because it's like when you
don't have a you just want to do
something you know you want to do
something but you but everyone tells me
not to do it but my mind tells me the
opposite I want to do it so it's like so
it's like you know I I think definitely
everyone else is like you know I'll have
all my friends or my mom my family say
do not do that do not do that I'm like
but I see but I think if I did this so
explain things better it was like yeah
but you don't understand the what can
happen to you if you do that but like
yes but I need to explain things better
you know if I don't say anything then
then everyone sees it this way but I
need to sew it this way you know you
know I mean it's very it's very you know
I mean so it's very complicated that
makes yeah yeah
all right Aaron thank you so much for
sharing your story yeah I wish you lots
of luck yeah thank you you're so young
man
maybe uh maybe something will
you'll figure out something to work
around this yeah eventually
because I see you have some great
qualities too so I'm sure you'll figure
something out yes all right thank you
very much yes